i think i have the puffiest puss it's
fat
i've touched you off for when your tube
gone just like this
i'm the number one chewing gum champion
how dare you and that is liza hello
divas it's me showhole and me blue
hydrangea and today we are playing
glamours besties
hi did we me
well we met in the work room of rupaul's
drag race uk season one and my first
impression of cheryl was that she was
obsessed with me
can you believe me looking around the
work room i think it was just very clear
that we were gonna get on straight away
because we had similar approaches and
everybody else was older so
[Laughter]
three two one
run one do you even know me i'd like to
think so but i feel like i'm gonna fail
terribly
oh well i know you inside android
what is my biggest pet peeve
well it's something i do to wind you up
something chronic and it's drag queens
that don't wear earrings oh that's why
i'm wearing them today to prove a point
she's wearing earrings today she's not
wearing tits that's my other pet peeve
and you're not wearing knickers which is
my other pet peeve but you got one of
them
i'll give you that okay i want to see if
you know this because i tweet about this
a lot what would give cheryl the egg
people that chew with their mouth open
so you
hey
you've never told me that before i've
talked you off for when your tube gone
oh it's just like this
coming
i'm the number one chewing gum champion
regardless
but what was your equity from your tweet
boys that wear
underwear under their swimwear is the
most disgusting thing i've ever seen in
my life like you have the little mesh
bit it looks after your willy you do not
need to wear your calvin kleins
underneath your swimsuit it's just like
no i look at boys and i go
right number three
what is my alcoholic beverage of choice
oh it's a body coke all the time three
months ago that would be correct but
i've recently been informed by my
boyfriend that i am a diva on
vodka coke
so i've had to change to a little
bacardi and coke not us being very drunk
one night in mavericks in belfast and
she goes you played it safe on drag race
well no i i'm allowed to because i won
yeah you can now yeah no no but not at
that time
i was on the vodka that night
who is my celebrity crush at the meet
and greet we always pick like little
like cute twinks well you pick out the
twins i'll pick out the dads that bring
their children oh okay there's a daddy
pierce brosnan
too much for daddy she and richie
okay i'll give you a hint
his son has just got married oh david
beckham
okay fair where would you fire me at a
shindig at a party oh the dance floor
truly i am with those people if the
tunes are pumping i am not leaving that
dance floor the minute there's a [ __ ]
song i'm gone if there's a food we'd be
we'll both be at the food place oh if
it's a beige buffet i'm there
what's that like sausage rolls sausage
rolls quiche lorraine
chicks and onion rolls chicken dippers
nachos crispies is brilliant oh my
goodness i'm queen of the buffet
[Music]
now it's time for round two and we are
playing who's who who are you oh i don't
know her
i have to say it's my only skill set so
let me have one thing do you want a
rematch no why would i show myself up
like that obviously she's gonna do
better
what makes you think that i'm home
i've seen you in a dressing room
johnson don't let this touch the floor
how dare you and that is liza maybe i'm
high maintenance on a vodka cook
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna lie if it came to a life
or death situation i feel like you would
run for the hills i feel like both of us
would just try and see ourselves yeah i
would give the skin off my own back to
make a coat for somebody i'm i'm a very
caring and nurturing person and she
looks after everyone she's a hostess
with the mostess and she yeah would
absolutely defend i mean a heartbeat
that's why we're friends
i was actually gonna say you because
she's been cracking up you could open
your mouth but she laughs see if i tell
jokes i make room laugh if you just say
anything in an essex accent ruse like
i'm not gonna say but roll the clips of
every time ruse said you're right babes
i've broken through
and before she could even say hello she
said something about my ugg boots and i
was like
it's not in a mean way no or a horrible
way
it's just poking fun it's a very
northern irish thing to do make fun of
your friends and take the mick
now this is this is no no like sizes
that i think i have the puffiest puss
it's fat
i was just gonna say that you don't
conceal it with like
panties or anything
like i wear we panty i make it look like
there's nothing there well i have my
tucking nicknack paddy wax but
it's still large and in charge
neither of us
i'm gonna say you
i'd like to say that i take good
leadership but when it comes down to
stressful situations like covertina and
parties that shouldn't have happened
i don't think i would deal well with the
stress and having to you know
listen to lots of people talking see i'm
queen of the [ __ ] world so for
me to be prime minister would be like a
real big stepdawn you know what i mean
plus i thought that you'd be a good
prime minister because your haircut
reminds me of forest johnson's
[Music]
it's this outfit
i just don't have a filter as much as
you think maybe i'm just like throwing
or that northern ireland in it but i
feel like we just don't think before we
speak back home
but
i've learned the hard way that sometimes
you can't say stuff in the moment
because you'll learn to regret it
why am i all the bad ones you get the
ones oh who's the latest person no
because i've caught her out several
times because i know she's lying like
it's always there i'm coming down now
from the hotel room i'm coming down now
oh sorry i'm just in the lift i'm coming
down now and she's having a [ __ ] on the
toilet
yeah that is true
yes
[Applause]
did i not win any money for this either
just a badge or something yeah
at the end of the day i saw it coming
because the the stars haven't aligned
just yet 2023 maybe that'll be my
winning year
and you know what i'm just glad that i
got to share today with you now let the
music play